vanya marks people you'll need the  toilet  too bad weather's nice mayhem has its  share of eccentric but let me introduce  the most volatile along this so-called  bombshell jewel is both labelled elevate  she's equally as comfortable walking the  runways in stilettos as engineering  murder terror and then there is Rama  the irony is not lost on me that the  world's foremost immunologist is herself  one of the most lethal forces of  destruction today is not your day no  team is complete without its lunatic red  car is a football obsessed psychopath  with a heart of gold  maybe silver Tywin repents when  circumstances are most dire  [Music]  when the pressure is absolute when only  the heavy artillery will do I Colin  Fitts bombshell  [Music]